dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly if a here the better
fluid simulation techniques out there
typically run on our graphical cards
which if we formulate the problem in a
way that the many compute units within
can do in parallel if they row in unison
if you will will be greeted by an
incredible bump in the speed of the
simulation this leads to amazingly
detailed simulations many of which
you'll see in this footage it's going to
be really good however sometimes we have
a simulation domain that is so large it
simply cannot be loaded into the memory
of our graphical card what about those
problems well the solution could be stop
dividing the problem into independent
subdomains and solving them separately
on multiple devices
slice the problem up into smaller more
manageable pieces
divide and conquer but wait we would
just be pretending that these subdomains
are independent because in reality they
are clearly not because there is a large
amount of fluid flowing between them and
it takes quite a bit of algebraic
wizardry to make sure that the
information exchange between these
devices happens correctly and on time
but if we do it correctly we can see our
reward on the screen let's marvel at it
together
oh oh yeah I cannot get tired of this
typically the simulation in the
individual subdomains are computed on
one or more separate graphical cards and
the administration of the intersecting
interface takes place on the processor
the challenge of such a solution is that
one has to be able to show that the
solution of this problem formulation is
equivalent to solving the huge original
problem and it also has to be
significantly more efficient to be
useful for projects in the industry the
paper is one of the finest pieces of
craftsmanship I've seen lately the link
is available in the video description
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time
[Music]